la palabra optimismo vuelve a estar
sobre la mesa en las negociaciones para
un acuerdo nuclear internacional con
irán
hay una posibilidad de que en el futuro
cercano seamos capaces de llegar a una
conclusión sobre el calendario de las
negociaciones probablemente asistiremos
a un nuevo ciclo de negociaciones
mantenemos el optimismo de que el
proceso de negociación nos lleve a un
resultado lógico y razonable
esta es la respuesta que ha dado teherán
a la última propuesta de la unión
europea un borrador presentado por el
jefe de la diplomacia del bloque josep
borrell que detalla el levantamiento de
las sanciones estadounidenses a iran y
la limitación de la actividad nuclear
del país persa según el diplomático
europeo es la opción más factible y es
urgente que todas las partes lo acepten
eeuu aseguró está revisando el texto
irán no ha querido no ha podido aceptar
un acuerdo para volver al pacto nuclear
volver al acuerdo es el mejor resultado
para eeuu irán y el mundo
[Música]
desde que en 2018 el ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump dinamitó el
pacto de 2015 retirando unilateralmente
a su país del acuerdo volver a construir
los puentes ha sido una misión imposible
incluso bajo el nuevo liderazgo de joe
biden desde febrero de 2021 la unión
europea se erigió como mediadora entre
washington y teherán con diálogos
indirectos que parecían infructuosos al
menos hasta ahora y en junio de este año
qatar albergó más conversaciones
indirectas entre ambos países que no
dieron ningún resultado
mientras las posiciones siguen enrocadas
irán insiste en que no tiene intención
de desarrollar una bomba nuclear pero
anunció que tiene ya la capacidad
técnica para hacerlo y mantiene las
cámaras del organismo internacional de
la energía atómica apagadas en sus
instalaciones a la vez las duras
sanciones de eeuu sobre la economía
iraní mantiene al país y a su gente en
una crisis económica sin fin